the war has taken a new turn in the last
month
Russia has been targeting Ukraine's
energy facilities a third have been
damaged so far
there are planned electricity blackouts
taking place across the country
in the city of trevori they're getting
ready for the cold weather
the industrial city was hit by a drone
according to authorities it's caused
considerable damage to the energy
facility
they say they've set up 300 heating
points around the city
the Russians continue to launch
terrorist attacks so we must be prepared
for the wars we're not trying to make a
five-star hotel this place is made to
survive the blankets food and baby cribs
this bunker can house hundreds of people
Tatiana left the donbass region in the
East after Russia invaded now the family
faces a harsh winter
we have everything here sleeping bags
and blankets a warm place for the worst
scenarios I think we won't phrase
this city has become home to internally
displaced people but crevory has been
targeted by Russian forces the prospect
of leaving again is a very real one
in another part of the city a Soviet era
nuclear bunker is being used to show a
football match authorities here say they
feel it's important to provide
entertainment watching a football match
in a nuclear bunker may not be normal
but it's a chance for them to come
together
I like the atmosphere here I'm cheering
for my football team and I believe we
will win
it would be better to watch it in the
stadium but we are here that's what we
have because of the situation in the
country
[Applause]
just for a moment they forget the war
outside and have something to cheer
about Assad